الوحل يشبه لعبة Pokey
اللزجة اللزجة مثل المياه اللاصقة. أحب هذا المكان.
المعهد 12000 قدم مربع من الفرح ،
يمكنك تغيير نفسك حقًا عندما
تأتي وتحصل على اسم الوحل الخاص بك
وهذا يمنحك هذا الإذن
للعب من هناك وتذهب في رحلة
حيث يمكنك مقلاع الوحل ، يمكنك
التخلص من الوحل عليك ، لدينا
كل نسيج تنبعث منه رائحة مختلفة في
كل لحظة هو اكتشاف تقوم
بصنع الوحل الخاص بك وأنت تمشي على
الوحل وأنت تلطخه على
الحائط وهناك مقاطع فيديو غامرة
وهناك  بحيرة من السلايم تزيد مساحتها عن 350 جالونًا
للسير على ما نسميه شاطئ اسفنجي ،
إنه يشبه مشروبي بالكامل ، إنه أمر
رائع تمامًا مثل فصل طين حيث
يمكنك صنع الوحل ثم نعود إلى
منزلنا هنا في السومو ، حيث يمكنهم صنع طعامهم حسب الطلب.
الوحل الخاص الذي يعد حقًا
خاصًا للعديد من الأطفال ليتمكنوا
من الاختيار من بين 60 رائحة مختلفة 40
لونًا مختلفًا ، هناك أكثر من 4 ملايين
مجموعة من السلايم يمكنهم صنعها هنا
تأكد من حصولك على ذلك واضح  ضيقة
ثم تنفجر ثم قاموا بضربها
[موسيقى]
كنا نعلم أن هناك جمهورًا ضخمًا
كان يتوق إلى الوحل الذي لا يُصدق
في الشهر الأول ، كان لدينا قائمة ضخمة من
الضيوف المشاهير مشينا في
يوم واحد وكنا مثل يا إلهي إنه
كيري  واشنطن ، إنها درو باريمور
تريسي مورغان وجيسيكا ألبا ، تعلمون
أنهم جميعًا يشاركونها أكثر من 60 من
زوارنا من خارج منطقة الولايات الثلاث ،
لذلك نحن نجتذب الجميع من
سكان نيويورك إلى أشخاص من أستراليا
يأتون إلى مدينة نيويورك فقط
لتجربة الليموزين
[الموسيقى]
الأجنبية
التي كانت ممتعة للغاية ، لقد توسلت إلى أمي
للقيام بذلك ، أوصي
بالذهاب بعد أن تعرف الوباء حيث
قضينا الكثير من الوقت مكبوتًا في المنزل ،
فالناس جائعون للقيام بأشياء نريدها  قد يذكرني شخص
يبلغ من العمر 70 عامًا ليأتي إلى هنا ويكون مثل
هذا بشبابي أو أن
هذا مريح حقًا ، لقد عملنا مع
معالج فيزيائي يتحدث عن كيف يمكن
للمشي على الوحل أن يقوي بالفعل
قلبك وكاحليك لذلك هناك
إليك الكثير من العناصر الأخرى
التي تتجاوز Child's Play عندما تكون
هنا ويمكنك فقط الاستفادة مرة أخرى من
إحساس الهروب وهذا هو
المهم وهذا ما نحتاجه ، شكرًا لك